if you have a craving it could be for
junk food maybe for a cigarette there's
a really effective way to diminish it
using games multiple studies have shown
that playing a game like Tetris or candy
crush saga can actually within three
minutes reduce your craving by twenty
five to fifty percent in their latest
study and here's how it works when you
have a craving you're really imagining
the thing that you're craving it's it's
vivid in your mind's eye you're
picturing it what it'll feel like when
you eat it or when you get what you want
the more vividly you imagine it in your
mind's eye the stronger the craving well
if you play a video game that really
preoccupies the visual processing center
of your brain then your brain can't
picture the thing you're craving so if
you pick a game that is very intense
visuals the kind of visuals that when
you walk away from the game and close
your eyes you'll still see the puzzle
pieces falling or you'll be having
flashbacks to the candy colored pizzas
swapping that's the kind of game that
has been shown in studies to effectively
reduce cravings and even though you know
25 to 50 percent craving it doesn't take
it away completely but studies have
shown that that is enough to help you
really make a smarter choice it gives
your willpower a fighting chance just to
get that little bit of reduction
you